this year's midterm elections could tip
the balance of power in congress
republicans need net gains of one senate
seat and four house seats to take
control of both chambers during the
midterm election a lot is at stake but
most importantly the most watched thing
here in washington is the battle for the
control of congress wsj national
politics reporter joshua jamerson
explains how democrats and republicans
have been shaping the conversation
around the economy abortion gun violence
immigration and student loan forgiveness
with the goal of persuading voters
americans are feeling the pain of
inflation as they face the biggest price
increases in four decades grocery bills
gas prices things like that where money
is impacting people's everyday lives i
would say that is definitely something i
hear from voters when i'm traveling on
the campaign trail some republican
candidates including senator ron johnson
who is seeking re-election in wisconsin
claim that the party controlling
washington now is responsible for rising
prices democrats are printing trillions
of dollars to pay for their massive
deficit spending inflation is the
democrats tax on the middle class that's
what you hear mostly from republicans is
that simply by curtailing what your
buying democrats are able to spend that
are present in washington and majorities
would have a positive impact on your
finances
democrats have countered that there is
more at work when it comes to inflation
than just government policies candidates
including georgia senator rafael warnock
point to supply chain issues and their
willingness to take on what they see as
price gouging what if i told you
shipping container companies have been
making record profits while prices have
been skyrocketing on you that's why i'm
pushing to hold them accountable
democrats have tried to explain this and
explain how they might need some of
those inflationary crushers but there's
a saying in politics that it's a lot
harder to explain and if you're
explaining you're already starting not
in a position of strength and that's
something democrats have tried to combat
the leak of a supreme court draft
opinion signaling the court's intention
to overturn roe v wade made abortion a
campaign issue even before the court
released its decision in late june that
definitely rippled across the campaign
trail i happen to be in georgia with a
few republican candidates there and they
immediately started talking about how
this was the victory for the republicans
republican leaders argued that this
long-sought victory will energize their
own voters the argument to voters was
this is what your vote for republicans
got you know this long-held decade-long
effort to get constitutional
originalists with more of a conservative
view on the supreme court to make these
decisions democrats are hoping this will
inject urgency into the midterm
elections
a woman's right to choose
reproductive freedom
is on the ballot in november
a survey of american adults shows
increased support for abortion access
according to a wsj poll some 57 of
respondents said a woman should be able
to obtain legal abortions for any reason
how that relates to a political issue is
a big question and one that i don't
think we'll get an answer to until
november
[Music]
a string of mass shootings in the u.s
reignited the debate around laws to curb
gun violence and has led to the passage
of the first major federal change to gun
laws in decades
while many congressional democrats
support aspects of the bipartisan
legislation that includes funding for
red flag laws and mental health programs
some don't think the package goes far
enough now of course this bill doesn't
do everything we need not by a mile we
all understand this is a compromise
democrats generally would agree that
universal background checks is something
that they would like to see and then
underneath that there's some support for
fanning certain assault weapons
but many congressional republicans have
insisted the democrats efforts to change
u.s gun laws or further restrict access
to firearms is not the answer their
so-called solutions
wouldn't have stopped these mass murders
and they
know this
in addition to issues of shared interest
among republicans and democrats the two
parties also have their individual
focuses
republican candidates are betting
immigration is one voters care about
republican representative kevin mccarthy
who is the frontrunner to become house
speaker if the party wins control in
november argues the biden
administration's immigration policy has
allowed dangerous drugs to flow into the
u.s
fentanyl
is now the number one killer to
americans between the ages of 18 and 45.
there is no longer a few border cities
every city in america is now a border
city it really is about this idea that
the southern border is porous and
democrats won't stop people from
illegally crossing into the country
democrats however have been talking
about student loan forgiveness as a
candidate president biden proposed for
giving ten thousand dollars of federal
student loan debt per borrower democrats
remember that and they're kind of
disappointed that it hasn't happened yet
biden is likely to decide on a student
loan forgiveness plan later this summer
aimed in part at motivating young voters
to cast ballots but some republicans are
betting this will backfire and be met
with resentment for many voters many
also argue that forgiving student loan
debt would add to the national debt and
further fuel price rises republicans
counter the economy is already really
really high and canceling student loan
debt could just add more articulation
republicans will say if you send us to
washington give us control of the house
that's in it we can act as a check on
this joe biden presidency